In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for July 25, on which we commemorate, the 165 Holy Fathers
of the 5th Ecumenical Council in Constantinople, convoked by the devout Emperor Justinian, who had
taken as the goal of his reign the reconciliation of the churches that had been cruelly divided
since the Council of Calcedon.
The 5th Holy Ecumenical Council brought together in Constantinople, from the 5th of May to
the 2nd of June in the year 553, 165 bishops under the Presidency of the Holy Patriarch
of Thee heals.
The immediate object of this assembly was to regulate the matter of the three chapters,
that is, Theodore of Mopswesta, his friend, the brilliant Theodorethus of Cyrus, and their
disciple Ibus of Edessa.
Greatly honored in the east for his commentaries on the Holy Scripture, Theodore of Mopswesta
was the head of the School of Antioch.
Having given an exaggerated place in his theology to rational speculation and the axioms
of Aristotle's philosophy, he had gone as far as rejecting the possibility of a true union
between the created and the uncreated in the person of Christ.
For him, the word did not become man, but the human will was united in him, with a divine
will, preserving the distinction of the two natures and, therefore, of the two persons.
This is why he is considered to be the father of Nestorianism.
After the condemnation of Nestorius by the Council of Ephesus in the year 431, the latter's
partisans turned to the writings of Theodore, who had died in the peace of the church.
To interpret the Christological dogma, St. Cyril of Alexandria, although he had written against
him, intervened for him, with St. Proklus, not to demand the condemnation of his writings,
in order to preserve the peace of the church that had been achieved with such difficulty
in the year 438.
But Yutakis, rejecting this conciliatory attitude, had succeeded through his intrigues in making
monophysitism ratified by means of the Robert Council of Ephesus in the year 449, during
the course of which Thildoretus and Ibas, the two principal disciples of Theodore and
representatives of his theological tendency, were condemned.
At the Council of Calcedon in the year 451, Thildoretus and Ibas, after long hesitation, agreed
to place the Anathema on Nestorius and were re-established in the communion of the church.
After this, the interpretation and acceptance of the 4th Ecumenical Council allowed space
for new dissensions, which crystallized in the question of the three chapters.
The political measures taken by Emperor Zeno, the Enoticon and Patriarch Achaus, to win over
the opponents of the council, failed miserably, and even provoked a 35-year schism in the
year 484 through 519, between the Eastern and Western churches, the latter of which, keeping
closely to the letter of the council, turned into a defense of the three chapters.
Emperor Justin, having put an end to this schism, Justinian deciding to fight the Nestorian
tendency in the interpretation of the doctrine of Calcedon, published a decree against the
three chapters, which once again provoked a violent reaction in the West in the year 545.
Summoned to Constantinople, Pope Vihilius declared as soon as he arrived that he had broken
communion with the Holy Patriarch Minas, who responded with the same action.
After considerable fuss, Vihilius agreed to be reconciled with Minas and produce a document
Judicatum, which condemned the three chapters.
This document was seen as a betrayal by the churches of Africa and Aquileia, and this brought
about a long and painful division in the heart of the Western Church, while the East,
for its part, found it too tepid.
When it had been decided to convene an ecumenical council to put an end to the quarrel, Justinian
published a confession of faith in which he made his own the characteristic expressions of
the theology of Saint Cyril, that were opposed by the Western adherence of the three chapters
in the year 551.
Pope Vihilius rejected this document, and from that time onwards never stopped placing obstacles
in the way of the council's meeting.
It's opening, having been the more delayed by the death of Saint Minas, the fathers began
the sessions under the presidency of his successor, Saint Ethiheos, who expressed his sorrow
at the Pope's opposition.
Vihilius declared that he completely endorsed the orthodoxy of Thildoretos and Ibas, but
during its eighth session, the council nevertheless proceeded to the condemnation of the three chapters
and placed the anathema on all who defended them.
Although without condemning the Pope by name, in December Vihilius submitted to the council's
decisions, but it was only nearly two years later that he himself condemned the three chapters
in the year 555.
At a preconceilier conference, the fathers also condemned the doctrine of origin, Evagrius
and Didymus of Alexandria, on the pre-existence of the soul, its fall in the body, and the universal
restoration apocatastases which denied human freedom.
Having averted a schism between East and West, the Holy Council of Constantinople put
an end to the Nestorian current with its condemnation of all the heretical proposals
of Theodore of Mopswesta, and it confessed the full conformity of the council of Calcedon
with the faith confessed by the third ecumenical council of Ephesus, emphasizing that it is indeed
the person of God, the Word, who suffered in the flesh, the opacatism, and thus opened to
us the path to deification.
The council recognized the theology of Saint Cyril as a rule of faith, in the way in which
it is understood in the light of the dogma of Calcedon.
It is rightly seen as an ecclesiastical council par excellence, for rejecting the theological
speculation in the questions of dogma, whether under the rationalist and Aristotelian form
of Theodore of Mopswesta or that of the spiritualized neoplatanism of the originists.
It affirmed that the church has its true apostolic interpretation of the mystery of Christ,
thanks to which it safeguards the integrity of human freedom and the possibility of its
being fully united to God in the person of the Savior.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.